ein euro 60 für den liter diesel 1 euro
80 für den liter super tanken macht
keinen spaß zurzeit die spritpreise
haben den höchststand seit 2012 erreicht
und auch für heizöl strom und gas müssen
wir wesentlich mehr bezahlen was
bedeutet das dann für verbraucher und
für unternehmen die debatte über energie
zuschüsse die ist eröffnet und über
allem schwebt dann die frage wie der
klimaschutz zu finanzieren ist
schwierige aufgabe für die ampel
koalition teure energie was tun gegen
den preisschock unser thema heute in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf ihnen
meine gäste vorstellen ja so kurz vor
den koalitionsverhandlungen ist bei uns
michael theurer stellvertretende
vorsitzender der fdp-fraktion er ist
auch mitglied im fdp präsidium und
vorsitzender der fdp baden-württemberg
am haus dort von dort ist er uns auch
zugeschaltet schönen guten abend herr
teurer
und ich begrüße katja augen blitzen ich
begrüße katja kipping von den linken sie
ist ehemalige parteivorsitzende ist
jetzt auch wieder mitglied des
zwanzigsten deutschen bundestages und
ihr wahlkreis ist dresden schönen guten
abend frau kipping
in jugend und hier im studio ist klaus
müller seit 2014 ist er vorstand des
verbraucherzentrale bundesverband ist
und er war auch mal grüner
umweltminister in schleswig holstein und
bei uns ist hans-jürgen fels
chefvolkswirt des bundesverbandes
mittelständische wirtschaft bvmw denn
wir wollen sich auch wissen was es für
die unternehmen bedeutet dass die
energiepreise so steigen man merkt es
fast 20 prozent teurer herr müller
diesel so fast so teuer wie noch nie ist
das jetzt sozusagen ja ein einmaliger
ausrutscher mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen ursachen oder müssen wir
uns einfach darauf einstellen dass
energie in zukunft für uns alle teurer
wird wahrscheinlich ist beides richtig
also wir haben jetzt gerade eine
situation wo nach dem kalten letzten
winter doch eher überschaubar gefüllten
gasspeichern der konjunktur in asien
bestimmten problemen mit russland wie
eine bestimmte situation haben die dänen
die die geschwindigkeit des
preisanstieges bestimmt haben und damit
haben wir eben einen winter vor uns der
womöglich mit energiepreisen des grauens
für manche verbraucher verbraucher
verbunden ist aber darüber hinaus gilt
alle parteien haben zu recht gesagt
energie muss einen ehrlichen preis
bekommen fossile energie muss einen
ehrlichen preis bekommen und darum
glaube ich kann man sich nicht
zurücklehnen und hoffen dass das problem
weil eben wieder vorbeigeht man muss
darauf politisch reagieren das wie wir
das machen wir gleich aber sie sagen
erstmals geht erstmal so nicht so
schnell vorbei ist wird erst mal so
bleiben
herr falls was bedeutet das für die
unternehmen die jetzt halt eben jetzt wo
die konjunktur wieder etwas an läuft
nach corona die jetzt auf einmal oder es
wird wirklich teuer das ist richtig es
stimme ja nur dazu natürlich hat die
wirtschaft das auch schon mit
eingepreist nur dieser sprung in dieser
höhe ich würde doch ergänzen würden die
entwicklung des us dollar spielt
natürlich auch noch eine rolle was die
höhe des ölpreises angeht ist natürlich
in der kurzen frist nicht so leicht
wegzustecken als wenn man eine längere
übergangsfristen das heißt in der kürze
der zeit eine vielzahl von belastungen
für die wirtschaft
neben der korona krise die hohe
bürokratie belastung die ja nach wie vor
gegeben ist und wo es bedauerlicherweise
bislang auch keine signale dahingehend
gibt dass diese abgebaut wird die neben
den hohen energiepreisen die
sozialabgaben quote die in stream hoch
ist in deutschland auch dort zeichnet
sich tendenziell eher an den weg nach
oben ab wir werden über die 40 prozent
kommen das in der summe herrn ist eine
große belastung für die wirtschaft und
jetzt sehen bislang keinerlei signale
auch nicht aus den sondierungsgesprächen
heraus dass diese entlastung kommen wird
also würden sie sich ganz konkret
wünschen für unternehmen konkret wäre
dass die hoffnung dass das sollte
möglichst noch die alte bundesregierung
die amtierende bundesregierung in
angriff nehmen dass die pendlerpauschale
erhöht wird möglicherweise auch in
absprache mit den neuen koalitionären
und was natürlich auch ein punkt ist der
uns sehr wichtig ist ist dass die
energie steuer früher genannt
mineralölsteuer auf superbenzin und auch
auf diese halbiert wird okay ganz
konkrete forderungen fragen wir doch mal
denjenigen der schon bei den
sondierungsgesprächen mit dabei war und
jetzt koalitionsverhandlungen bald in
angriff nehmen muss her teurer ganz
konkrete forderungen und hohe
energiepreise ist muss eine entlastung
geben herford pendlerpauschale und halt
eben mineralölsteuer ist das was was sie
sich vornehmen für die verhandlungen
also zunächst mal hat der herr müller
und darauf hingewiesen dass wir in
deutschland von globalen
marktentwicklungen abhängig sind wir
haben die aufholjagd in china wir hatten
einen trockenen sommer mit geringen
wasser- kraftreserven kalten winter das
alles geht jetzt in die energiepreise
hinein und es gibt versäumnisse der
vergangenheit was das hochfahren der
regenerativen energien angeht und auch
das thema leitungsbau so dass die
offshore wind produktion von nordsee und
ostsee überhaupt zu den verbrauchern im
süden geleitet werden können diese
versäumnisse die eh schon da sind fallen
jetzt in dieser situation ganz besonders
ins gewicht und wir sagen ganz klar und
so steht zum beispiel ja auch im
sondierungs papier von spd grünen und
fdp dringen dass wir zum beispiel was
die planungs beschleunigung und die
beschleunigung von genehmigungsverfahren
angeht beschleunigen wollen auf
mindestens die hälfte wir wollen
außerdem entlastungen hier auch umsetzen
wie zum beispiel das auslaufen der eeg
umlage
das alles wirkt dämpfend aber generell
ist es natürlich so das merken wir jetzt
dass neben klimaschutz
versorgungssicherheit und bezahlbarkeit
bei der energie ein thema ist und ich
glaube wir so dass das hat im
europäischen kontext uns anschauen und
da hat er die eu kommission klar
empfohlen mit einem werkzeug gast mit
einer toolbox die diese woche
vorgestellt worden ist dass die
mitgliedstaaten nicht in die
marktdynamik eingreifen sollte weil
angebot und nachfrage effiziente
zuteilung systeme sind aber gefährdet
die gruppen vor allen dingen auch
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher die
sozial schwach sind da muss man
natürlich schon darüber sprechen wie man
die entlasten kann oder wie man den
bedürftigsten helfen kann zum beispiel
auch über grundsicherung und wohngeld ok
also da sagen sie ganz da muss es eine
entlastung geben all die anderen sachen
werden ja länger erstmal dauern also bis
dann wirklich die leitungen alle gebaut
sind auch wenn es jetzt schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren gibt dauert es ja
frau kipping das wird sie doch
wahrscheinlich freuen wenn die neue
koalition von der von wohngeld und
grundsicherungs erhöhung da spricht was
fordern sie was muss da passieren damit
verbraucher jetzt oft mit diesen hohen
energiepreisen umgehen können
sie haben ja von gefragt womit wir uns
womöglich abfinden müssen und ich kann
nur sagen es geht etwas womit wir uns
auf keinen fall abfinden müssen ja auch
nicht dürfen nämlich dass es hierzulande
menschen gibt die von strom und
gas schweren betroffen sind und das wir
je nachdem welche berechnung mal in zwei
bis drei millionen menschen haben die
jetzt schon ihre wohnung nicht
angemessen warm anheizen können und
diese sind so dieses soziale not wird
sich noch einmal verschärfen und da gibt
es instrumente dagegen ich möchte mal
wenn also eine möglichkeit ist dafür
streiten wir als linke seit längerem zu
sagen dass die tatsächlich anfallenden
stromkosten für die sieben millionen die
auf sozialleistungen regelbedarfe
angesprochen sind es die einfach die mit
den kosten der unterkunft komplett
übernommen bekommen da geht es jetzt
sind sie mit der sondierungsrunde und
zwar von robert habe und das fand ich
erschreckend europa habe robert habeck
hat sehr klar gesagt wenn man die strom-
und heizkosten übernimmt wäre das ein
anreiz für fenster auf und heizung auch
das heißt doch aber im klartext dass er
jetzt die last des energiesparens und
ich brenne wirklich für die ökologische
für die energiewende aber was robert
habeck mit diesem spruch gesagt hat ist
im klartext die last der co2 einsparung
wird jetzt auf den ersten abgewälzt und
bedeutet kollektives frieren für die
ernsten das ist ein vernichten das
signal ich würde fast sagen diesen
spruch den er da von sich gegeben hat es
ist also wenn ihr mir dass dafür jemand
gesagt hätte dass er verspricht ich
gesagt das ist die karikatur sozusagen
eine sozial ignorant mit einer
wohlstands pro jahr das ist natürlich
verheerend weil man kann jetzt nicht
sagen es ist uns egal was den ernsten
geht hier kaufe sofortmaßnahmen wie zum
beispiel die übernahme der tatsächlichen
stromkosten oder eben mehr heizkosten
zuschlag im auch für auch für alle
wohngeld beziehen ok haben wieder was
empfinden sie diesen spruch von robert
habeck wenn er sagt das ist ein
schlechtes signal
also ich weiß nicht in welchem kontext
der gefallen ist und insofern bin ich
mir nicht sicher ob es schlau ist
einzelne sätze zu zitieren ohne den
kontext diskussion zu kennen was erstmal
richtig ist und das hat auch herr teurer
gesagt dass wir die unterstreichen man
muss unterscheiden ob man gegen die
allgemeinen markt preisanstiege angehen
möchte darum teile ich auch nicht den
vorschlag von der welt zu sagen wir
halbieren mal eben die steuer für alle
weil ich glaube dass es kein
finanzminister bezahlen kann sondern
richtig ist wir müssen uns um die
menschen kümmern die bedürftig sind und
mit dem wohngeld gibt es dafür ein alles
in einem gutes instrument in deutschland
das könnte noch etwas einfacher und
unbürokratischer ausfallen aber das ist
erst mal richtig zweiter
viele haushalte mit geringem einkommen
haben vergleichsweise ineffiziente
haushaltsgeräte also wenn sie angucken
wie ein hartz4 haushalt ausgestattet ist
das häufig kühlschränke die
überdurchschnittlich viel energie
verbrauchen das heißt man muss beim
thema energieeffizienz ansätzen
verbraucherzentralen caritas und andere
haben damit schon erfahrung gesammelt in
nordrhein-westfalen in anderen
bundesländern das heißt man muss sehr
zielgenau helfen und ich glaube aus der
kombination wird ein schuh draus richtig
wäre auch über weitere anreize
nachzudenken und da sind wir eben bei
fragen wie die co2 aufschläge für mieter
und vermieter aufgeteilt werden ich
glaube da die nächste koalition noch
einiges an gesprächen vor aber man will
doch auch einen anreiz schaffen dass man
weniger energie verbraucht das ist
vollkommen war ich würde auch immer als
verbraucherschützer sagen energie
braucht einen ehrlichen preis und
insofern finde ich ist das vor den
preisanstiegen richtig gewesen und das
gilt heute immer noch der punkt ist nur
die geschwindigkeit des anstieges die
muss man einsatz noch die muss man im
blick behalten damit ich mich darauf
einstellen kann weil gerade ärmere
haushalte können nicht mal eben einen
neuen kühlschrank kaufen ein neues
elektroauto das können sie nicht und da
muss von dort zielgenau helfen ansonsten
jahr energie braucht einen ehrlichen
preis das ist eine harte aber ehrliche
wahrheiten helfer etwas würde das aber
bedeuten sie sagen moment kurz erfüllt
sind dann wie vor keeper hält wenn sie
wenn man sagt man was sie möchten dass
man die mineralölsteuer eben stark
runter fährt ist dass sich dann anreiz
um wieder mehr auto zu fahren statt
öffentlichen nahverkehr zu nutzen also
genau eben nicht im sinne des
klimaschutzes zu handeln weil dem
vorschlag des bundesverbands
mittelständische wirtschaft handelt sich
um eine temporäre reduzierung also keine
dauerhafte sondern für den zeitraum wo
diese spitze derzeit existiert ich als
überzeugter marktwirtschaftler der krise
arbeits universität von kiel hat
natürlich eine keinerlei bedenken dass
die marktkräfte wieder zu einem
gleichgewichtspreis führen während aber
dieser anstieg innerhalb der kurzen zeit
der winkel ist abzufedern und dafür
halte ich dieses mittel durch
ausprobiert und ich gebe auch zu
bedenken dass es im bereich des agrar
dieses also land und forstwirtschaft
schon jetzt eine wenn man so will
privilegierung gibt für den verbrauch in
diesen bereichen also es wäre kein neues
instrumentarium ganz im gegenteil es ist
schon eingeübt das müsste nur für diesen
zeit kurz befristeten zeitraum
ausgedehnt werden auf alle anderen auch
frauke denkt sie wollten was sagen dazu
ja weil mich ärgert in debatten also
nicht in dieser wunderbaren politisch
noch ausmacht wenn so der eindruck
erweckt wird dass ob jetzt die ernsten
leute just die größten
energieverschwender sind das ist
nachweislich nicht der fall also das
überhaupt nämlich einfach ich sondern
das statistische bundesamt hat
entsprechende studieren wenn sie den
aktuellen armuts und reichtumsbericht
sehen gibt es ja auch noch mal eine
übersicht wir wissen je größer und die
reiche ein haushalt ist umso größer ist
sein strom und energiebedarf das liegt
daran dass die einfach größere räume
haben mehr geräte haben am ende noch im
swimmingpool der beheizt werden muss
also wenn man ran durfte anders sparen
von energie auch um die co2 emissionen
zuständen zu reduzieren dann sollte man
nicht anfangen dem ernsten sozusagen das
frieren aufzudrücken sondern dann muss
man anfangen mit dem reichtums
begrenzung oder in diesem bereich
reingehen deswegen ist er so ärgert mich
diese ignoranz gegenüber
energiearmut die ja wirklich eine
existenzielle form von armut ist so und
ich wollte ja noch mal ein punkt der
verbraucherzentrale unterstreichen das
ist eine frage die teure haushalt können
sich ärmere haushalte
auch ein stromsparendes gerät leisten
nein das große problem ist sogar und
seitdem hat hier erfunden wurde kämpfen
die sozialverbände und auch ich
persönlich immer wieder darum dass es
die möglichkeit gibt dass der erwerb der
sogenannten weißen ware also zum
beispiel im kühlschrank oder eine
waschmaschine dass wenn die anfällt was
die halt dann direkt bezuschusst wird
und dann hat auch ein stromsparendes
modellfall tatsache ist man erwartet von
dem hautarzt vier haushalt dass er
faktisch über 16 jahre jeden monat und
es war ein euro 90 oder sowas zurücklegt
und an spart für den zweites mal der
kühlschrank kaputt geht was er dann
einen neuen kaufen kann dafür sind aber
dass sozialleistungen viel zu knapp
bemessen das ist vollkommen unmöglich
dass die serie zurück sparen und es soll
ja unteren kaputt geht dann soll er auch
reformiert werden frau kipping herr
teurer was ist das ist dieselbe wie die
energie preisdiskussion ist das eben
wirklich eine soziale diskussion jetzt
also bei dem was frau kipping jetzt
gerade geschildert hat da schwang bier
zerrbild mit weil da ein kommen stärkere
bürgerinnen und bürger praktisch den
unterstellt wurde dass sie praktisch da
mehr energie verbrauchen oder mehr co2
ausstoßen und ich glaube dass uns eine
debatte in der auch ich glaube dass eine
debatte in der so unterschwellig
vielleicht auch ein stück mitschwingt
uns nicht weiter hilft denn bei dem was
wir als freie demokraten wollen was auch
den geist des und die jungs papiers
prägt geht es ja darum die externen
kosten der klima verschmutzung zu
internalisieren also spricht co2 einen
fairen preis zu geben und das bedeutet
dass derjenige der mehr co2 ausstößt
dafür bezahlt und das bedeutet dann dass
derjenige der einkommen stärke ist sich
vielleicht auch mehr leisten kann aber
an anderer stelle kommt das geld rein
wir wollen das geld nutzen zum beispiel
für eine klima dividende grünen haben
was ähnliches vorgeschlagene energie
geld wo praktisch dann pro kopf die
einnahmen aus der co2 verpressung
zurückgegeben werden an die bürgerinnen
und bürger und davon werden
einkommensschwächere wesentlich stärker
profitieren als einkommen stärker als
ich glaube das problem dass geschildert
worden ist ist erkannt und das sind
maßnahmen vorgesehen und in der
diskussion und ich hoffe sehr dass die
auch umgesetzt werden aber ich will den
aspekt der herr müller noch mal betont
hat auch in abgrenzung zur frau kipping
hier noch mal beleuchten ich glaube es
bringt nichts wenn wir klimaschutz
wirklich erreichen wollen dass es keine
anreize zum energiesparen gibt und das
ist völlig unabhängig von der
einkommenssituation wenn wir zum
beispiel bei grundsicherungsempfänger
und wohngeldempfängern werden wir die
energiekosten bei den pauschalen
mitberücksichtigt unter müssen steigende
energiepreise nach meinem dafürhalten
auch einfließen aber wir sollten nicht
einfach pauschal egal wie viel jemand
verbraucht strom und energiekosten über
den steuerzahler abdecken sodass kein
anreiz mehr besteht energie zu sparen
das würden auch diejenigen die in die
sozialkassen und als steuerzahler
einbezahlen nicht verstehen wenn wir
klimaschutz erreichen wollen brauchen
wir auch anreize zum energiesparen
das muster richtige weg sein und genau
da schlagen lassen das gilt für die
verbraucher und die geringverdiener
herfällt aber was heißt das dann für die
unternehmer wenn man sich darauf
einstellen muss dafür unter in für die
unternehmen man sagt man co2 man muss
dem co2 preis bezahlen energie wird
teurer
das wird doch dann aber auch wieder an
die kunden nun die konsumenten
weitergegeben oder also vollkommen wir
das nicht überwälzt werden können
vielleicht damals den markt für die
zuschauer von bedeutung sein es ist ja
schon jetzt so dass auf einen liter
diesel 47 cent anfallen dazu kommt die
mehrwertsteuer also 47 cent
energiesteuern die mehrwertsteuer kommt
dazu und die co2 abgabe
sechs bis acht zehntel habe ich so im
bereich liegt dass diese co2 abgabe
dürfte auch zukünftig weiter steigen das
ist schon jetzt absehbar und dafür
erhalte ich also nicht vermessen dass
man für einen gewissen zeitraum also
zeitlich befristet den vorschlag den wir
gemacht haben auch aufgreift seitens der
politik und wir dürfen nicht vergessen
mit dem steigenden preis nimmt der
jetzige finanzminister olaf scholz und
auch der zukünftige finanzminister
dann sicherlich auch er zukünftig sehr
sehr hohe einnahmen ein die dann auch
verteilt werden könnten soziale zwecke
habe ich möchte den aspekt von frau
kipping den ich durchaus nachvollziehen
kann so wie sie es geschildert hat sehr
plastisch mit der in ansammeln von euro-
beträgen über jahre hinweg um sich dann
einer waschmaschine oder kühlschrank zu
leisten das ist schon ein wenig der
realitätsfernen unser ziel als
wirtschaft insbesondere des
mittelstandes ist natürlich dass die
rahmenbedingungen für unternehmen in
deutschland so verbessert werden dass
investition nicht nur erhaltungs oder
reinvestition neue investitionen hier am
standort deutschland getätigt werden und
die an sich schon schwierig mit den
extrem hohen strompreisen sowie eine
rolle aber ich möchte gern auf den
aspekt dass diese arbeitsplätze in
deutschland zu möglichst andacht für
genutzt werden dass diejenigen die es
grund leistungsempfänger sind auf den
arbeitsmarkt zurückkehren können und
nicht weiter ein grund
leistungsempfänger sein müssen dass es
unsere haupt intension so dass auch der
wohlstand in deutschland weitestgehend
verteilt wird ja aber trotzdem noch mal
ich werde sagen
temporär soll jetzt diese steuer gesenkt
werden aber auf was müssen die
unternehmen sich nicht darauf einstellen
dass sie auch in zukunft höhere
energiepreise ebenfall müssen das was
bedeutet das für konsumenten das tun die
unternehmen bereits mich schon sagte
nicht alles kann abgewälzt werden
teilweise wird es auch so sein dass
energieintensive produktion vom standort
deutschland verlagert wird ins
europäische ausland
wo die energiekosten deutlich niedriger
sind
frankreich oder auch osteuropa markt
dort eine alternative sein das ist
natürlich nicht im interesse derjenigen
unternehmen die wir hier vertreten als
bundesverband mittelständische
wirtschaft sondern ganz im gegenteil
unser ziel ist es dass die
rahmenbedingungen hier in deutschland
günstiger seien durch brachte die
bürokratie ebene ansprache die ebene der
sozialabgaben an und die energiepreise
kann ich da auch nicht von ausnehmend
freundlich nachvollziehbar dass in
deutschland die stromkosten extrem hoch
sind und die begründen die dafür
geliefert wird die sich als sehr
fadenscheinig an und die
nicht auf die eeg umlage sich den punkt
hinzufügen trust das finden wir sehr
positiv dass dies angedacht wird
perspektivisch das sollte aber wenn es
dann geht nur wie schnell umgesetzt
werden okay herr müller sie wollten dass
entgegen er teurer dann auch
nochmal der nächste finanzminister wer
immer das sein wird wird vor großen
haushaltsproblemen stehen und ich glaube
in so einer situation ist eine pauschale
steuersenkung für alle egal über welche
unternehmensgewinne sie verfügen über
welches einkommen sie verfügen schlicht
nicht fair sondern ich habe noch einmal
dafür und freue mich sehr dass ich bei
ein teurer und ob er vor kipping dafür
unterstützung höre diese unterstützung
muss man fokussieren auf die menschen
die wirklich bedürftig sind erstens
zweitens
auch das thema und
dann wird man über unternehmen reden
müssen tatsächlich ein problem haben wo
mich gerade gewinne zu erzielen dafür
gibt es verschiedene instrumente wir
haben in der ganzen prohner krise
verschiedene instrumente gehabt und auch
den unternehmen zu helfen die bedürftig
sind es gibt aber auch unternehmen die
gerade hervorragende gewinne machen dass
du nicht ihnen von herzen die brauchen
aber keine steuerentlastung zurzeit weil
das ja von uns allen als steuerzahlerin
steuerzahler zu finanzieren werden noch
ein zweiter satz ich höre jetzt immer
die forderung nach einer erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale dazu muss man einmal
kurz ins einkommensteuergesetz gucken
eine pendlerpauschale funktioniert so
dass menschen mit einem höheren
einkommen überdurchschnittlich davon
profitieren menschen mit geringerem
einkommen wenig und menschen die gar
keine steuer zahlen für die ist die
pendlerpauschale nicht das richtige
instrument an der stelle und darum ganz
im geiste des ampelkoalition
sondierungsergebnisse auch hier glaube
ich muss man sich auf die fokussieren
die es nötig haben und wenn wir schlagen
ein einkommensunabhängiger mobilitäts
geld vor tatsächlich so machen dass
wirklich alle davon gleichermaßen
profitieren also da vertraue ich der
kreativität der ampel ok herr teurer
jetzt ist ihre müller vertraut ihrer
kreativität ich bin da ganz gerne mal
von ihnen etwas hören eben zu den
unternehmen wie man jetzt wenn er fällt
sagt das ist ein grund um mit den
standort jetzt sofort zu verlassen dann
ist das ja nichts positives
also die belastung der unternehmen durch
kosten steuern und abgaben und auch
durch bürokratie ist schon etwas was man
im auge behalten muss sie wissen wir als
freie demokraten sind der meinung dass
der entlastet werden muss wir haben da
in den gesprächen mit den potenziellen
koalitionspartnern
hart gerungen und wenigstens zusätzliche
neue steuern und neue belastungen
ausschließen können und auch einige
entlastungen die eeg-umlage ist
angesprochen worden aber auch super
abschreibung sind im papier erwähnt hier
mit hinein verhandeln können das ist ein
erster schritt aber ich will diesen
aspekt den herr müller angesprochen hat
mit dem was erfüllt gesagt hat noch mal
beleuchten die unternehmen in
deutschland sind bereits belastet wie
die verbraucher auch durch die höchsten
stromkosten sowohl im industriebereich
als auch im verbraucherbereich und ein
großer teil dieser stromkosten ist
staatlich verursacht und deshalb müssen
wir die aktuellen strom- und
energiekrise mal durch diskutieren was
schadet dem standort und was können wir
tun denn wenn andere standorte und diese
steigenden energiepreise die ja durch
globale märkte bestimmt sind bei gas und
öl die treffen auch die
wettbewerbsunternehmen der deutschen
unternehmen im ausland das wäre für den
standort deshalb nicht ganz so
dramatisch wenn also praktisch ist ein
globalen preisanstieg gibt
verschlechtert sich unsere relative
wettbewerbssituation nicht
problem für uns ist aber dass
deutschland der deutsche standort
insbesondere eben auch für
energieintensive unternehmen und für
mittelständische unternehmen die nicht
von der eeg-umlage befreit waren das die
mit hohen kosten belastet sind und die
abzusenken wollen wir die eeg-umlage
anders finanzieren nämlich über die co2
verpressung also auslaufen lassen und
wir sagen in dem maße in dem eben
kohlekraftwerke vom netz gehen in dem
jetzt die kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet
werden muss der ausbau der regenerativen
energien schritt halten und er muss
möglichst effizient also mit weniger
bürokratie mit schnelleren planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren stattfinden und
darauf haben wir uns im sondierungs
papier konzentriert also diese
praktischen probleme die von der
bisherigen noch amtierenden
bundesregierung nicht gelöst werden
können die müssen angepackt haben aber
auch das wird ja ein bisschen dauern bis
dann die regenerative ich würde gerne
weil herr papke bitte was würden sie
denn sagen was wie kann man die
unternehmen entlasten
also ich gebe zu das für mich als
sozialpolitikerin natürlich erstmal der
arbeitsschwerpunkt darauf liegt zu
verhindern dass jetzt menschen tieren
oder im dunklen sitzen da haben wir über
ein paar maßnahmen gesprochen was die
entlang situation der unternehmen
anbelangt so glaube ich muss man nochmal
unterscheiden es gibt unternehmen die
stehen vor einem transformationsprozess
da würde ich mich stark machen dass die
entsprechend mit einem transformation
skate und unterstützung finanziert
werden aber ich wollte gerne eine
kontroverse aufmachen auch zur ampel wo
sich ja in der steuerfrage muss man
sagen die fdp im komplett durchgesetzt
hat also ich sage leider aber
handwerklich haben sie da offensichtlich
das gut gemacht und spd und grüne
komplett über den tisch gezogen weil sie
haben bewirkt dass es keine höheren
steuern auch millionen erbschaften oder
millionen einkommen oder
millionenvermögen gibt das heißt aber
auch dass sie vor einer unlösbaren
mathematischen aufgabe stehen als ampel
weil wir jetzt über verschiedene dinge
gesprochen die steuerlich unterstützt
werden sollen die am selber ein paar
sozialmaßnahmen angesprochen dann soll
es investitionen in die erneuerbaren
energien und in die energiewende geben
und zugleich wollen sie die schulden
können sie beibehalten
es wird keine steuer mehr neben und dann
fällt natürlich was komplett untern
tisch was ich notwendig finde wir haben
ja nicht nur die sozial bedürftigen
sondern wir haben auch beschäftigte die
niedriges einkommen haben die von früh
bis abends rackern aber nicht noch
kinder haben und die halt für die dann
die steigenden energiekosten genau der
punkt wo sie von ich kann mir noch
winzig kleinen raum erlauben vielleicht
mal eine woche urlaub ein bisschen ich
komme gerade so über die runden das beim
und jetzt und diese truppe müsste man
auch entlasten wir hatten als linke
dafür vorschlag gemacht in der
einkommenssteuer das wäre finanzierbar
gewesen wenn man bereit wäre deutlich
höhere einkommen in angriff zu nehmen
dass diese entlastung der mitte hat
jetzt die fdp mit ihrem zu sagen schutz
von höheren steuern für millionen
einkauf erheben würden aber es gibt wird
ein mindestlohn soll es geben von zwölf
euro das würde ihnen ja dann
entgegenkommen das geringverdiener etwas
mehr verdient hat dass ich das ist es
das ist für jene die jetzt unter den
unter den zwölf euro die stunde arbeiten
die eine vollzeitstelle haben werden ja
auch noch menschen die trotzdem so
gerade an der grenze sind nah sondern
man zwölf euro vollzeit arbeitet und
womöglich zwei kinder umbringen muss und
dann schlagen höhere energiekosten zu
kann das hat zum beispiel bedeuten dass
die geplante woche familienurlaub auch
nach seinem patzer wollen sie danach
kurz darauf reagieren haben sie spd über
den tisch
also entscheiden bei dem was frau
kipping sagt ist doch dass auch ein
sozialpolitiker natürlich die wirtschaft
im blick halten muss denn die beste
sozialpolitik ist doch dass menschen
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
sind und dafür brauchen wir wachstum
nachhaltiges wachstum davon dafür
brauchen wir vor allen dingen dass die
betriebe und unternehmen die massiv
durch die korona pandemie gelitten haben
jetzt ein aufholprozess schaffen und das
in andere länder china die usa selbst
frankreich mit einem höheren
wirtschaftswachstum unterwegs als
deutschland deshalb muss man aufpassen
dass die unternehmen genug freiraum
haben und wenn wir jetzt mal über
familienunternehmen sprechen zu seinem
thema das auch kann schulz vom
bundesverband der mittelständischen
wirtschaft beschäftigen müsste wenn man
da das vermögen beispielsweise nicht
besteuert dann besteuert man die
substanz der unternehmen man treibt
familienunternehmen aus dem land und
davor können wir nur wenn wir also
wachstum wollen damit auch
steuereinnahmen und solide finanzen den
öffentlichen haushalten dann dürfen wir
eben die wirtschaft insbesondere die
mittelständische wirtschaft nicht
überbelasten und das ist das motiv warum
wir uns dafür eingesetzt haben eben
keine neuen steuern einzuführen und ich
bin froh dass die partner in den ampel
sondierungsgesprächen das genauso
gesehen haben oder dass wir dann fairen
kompromiss habe machen können die
anderen partner grüne spd finden sich
aber im papier ja genauso wieder wie die
fdp okay wir wollen jetzt keine
vermögenssteuer diskussion auf man sagen
wir bleiben noch mal bei den wirklich
bei den energiepreisen und dann auch
noch mal zu gucken was können wir denn
jetzt machen damit ist wieder günstiger
wird deshalb würde ich auch gerne mal
mit ihnen nach russland schauen und auf
das gas schauen da haben wir eine
diskussion über nord stream 2 und die
frage soll das früher in betrieb
genommen werden damit wir eben schneller
und mehr gas aus russland bekommen wie
finden sie es dass ist ja eine
hochpolitische diskussion fakt ist zum
glück leben wir in einem rechtsstaat und
aus guten gründen hat europa mit
deutscher unterstützung gesagt bei der
frage des gasmarktes ist zu
unterscheiden zwischen den versorgern
und den transporteuren und ich verstehe
den das sondierungsergebnisse von
freitag so dass die ampel noch mal
explizit bestätigt hat dieser
rechtsgrundsatz ist von der
bundesnetzagentur auch zu
berücksichtigen wenn es jetzt um die
genehmigung von 18 2 geht ich würde noch
ein anderer punkt machen uns hat gross
besorgt dass früher obwohl obwohl es
dazu führen würde dass die preise jetzt
ganz genau weiß man das nicht so genau
was herr putin oder gazprom dann machen
würde ich wäre beruhigter wenn die
gasspeicher in deutschland dieses jahr
so voll wären wie in den vorjahren da
waren wir jetzt ungefähr um die 90%
zurzeit sind wir plus minus bei 70
prozent und bei keiner weiß ob der
nächste winter kalt wird wäre ich hier
für vorsorge und ich würde mich vom
nächsten bundeswirtschafts
energieministerin wie auch immer
wünschen dass wir hier einen wesentlich
größeren wert darauf legen dass die
gasspeicher die wir in deutschland haben
gut gefüllt sind dass es erstens gut für
uns hier aber ist natürlich auch
solidarisch indem wir darauf achten dass
jemand der hier ein gasspeicher betreibt
auch in der verpflichtung steht ihnen zu
befüllen wir wissen dass gerade die
gazprom speicher leider
unterdurchschnittlich befüllt sind das
würde mich erfüllt mich mit sorge es ist
nicht nur gut für deutschland ist auch
gut für unsere nachbarn bei wenn wir
kurz nach großbritannien frankreich
spanien gucken dann ist da die
diskussion sogar noch härter als bei uns
gerade erfüllt wäre das eine entlastung
wenn man sagen würde man würde nord
stream käme doch früher überhaupt in
betrieb annalena baerbock hat gesagt ist
gegen die inbetriebnahme weil sie genau
dasselbe argument wie sie das eben die
produktion getrennt sein muss von dem
transport jetzt ist dieses diese
partnern aber fertig gesagt dass ich
richtig ist eine politische
grundsatzentscheidung
ich gehe aber so weit zu sagen bevor
hier in deutschland ist so ein blackout
kommt halte ich sogar für sinnvoller
sogar die laufzeiten von atomkraftwerken
zu verlängern weil nichts wäre schlimmer
als wenn es in deutschland zum blackout
käme und die gesamte wirtschaft stehen
wie wir haben jetzt schon im lager mit
der krone krise erlebt was bild was es
bedeutet wenn unternehmen nicht mehr
ihre eigenen geschäftstätigkeit
nachgehen sollten also alles was es
ermöglicht dass in deutschland sollen
die bänder nicht still stehen sondern
weiter laufen können und der standort
deutschland eine gewisse sicherheit
versorgungssicherheit auch erreicht
sollte meines erachtens nach auch
verfolgt werden befürchten sie dass
konkret was hören sie von ihren
unternehmen ist da die angst dass die
energie versorgung nicht gewährleistet
werden kann
häufig ist es schon so dass die also die
lieferketten problematik besteht
materialknappheit ich habe gerade erst
gespräche geführt die darauf hindeuten
dass letztendlich gar kein problem mehr
ist sowohl bei der energie nicht dann
ist es einfach die verfügbarkeit von
materialien es gibt einfach nicht
genügend sind stahl aluminium
grundstoffe die verarbeitet werden es
ist tatsächlich so dass es zu existent
existenziellen schwierigkeiten für den
unternehmen und man auf diese weise
hofft auch dass politisch laut während
unseres verbandes dass die politik
aufwacht und auch jetzt kurzfristig noch
maßnahmen ergreift die es den
unternehmen weiter ermöglicht ihre
tätigkeit nachzugehen und nicht alle so
sehen konkret auch noch mal von vorn
jetzigen bundeswirtschaftsminister alt
mein leben ganz besonders ja dann machen
das mal ganz konkret was muss etwas tun
die forderungen sind gestellt wurde sind
wenn unsere gratuliert worden und die
sind investors ministerium soweit ich
weiss auch angekommen es steht jetzt
eine reaktion aus es ist nicht so dass
die jetzige bundesregierung werden muss
bis sie abgelöst wird sie amtiert noch
und das sollte eigentlich dazu beitragen
dass sie in diesem bereich auch
aktivität entfaltet und ich darauf
wartet dass die neue koalition zusammen
kommt und sie die verantwortung von hier
abnimmt die fdp hat aber gesagt peter
altmaier hat soweit ich informiert man
auch gesagt er möchte gerne mit mit der
neuen ampel koalition über dieses thema
sprechen aber christian lindner hat das
angebot erst mal abgelehnt herr teurer
was könnte man denn was könnten sie denn
jetzt tun um den forderungen von
vollster nachzukommen die unternehmen zu
unterstützen sowohl was die energie
betrifft als auch all die anderen dinge
die im moment ist so schwierig machen
eben zu produzieren
also ich teile zunächst mal die kritik
an der bisherigen bundesregierung denn
ich habe beim 14 20 20 minister
aufgefordert in einem krisengipfel wegen
corona für die lieferketten sich
einzusetzen er hat mir dann im
deutschlandfunk geantwortet eine globale
krise sei nicht absehbar jetzt sind wir
mittendrin in einer logistikriese ist
fehlen chips fällen grundstoffe es
fehlen auch
rohstoffe es fehlt energie also es ist
insgesamt eine schwierige situation
und das hat verschiedene ursachen unter
anderem auch das zum beispiel matrosen
monatelang auf see waren das häfen wegen
corona fällen geschlossen sind das sind
alles themen die man jetzt abarbeiten
muss aber ganz konkret hilft der blick
zurück nicht sondern nur der blick nach
vorne und da stellt sich jetzt die frage
was können wir und was müssen wir
konkret tun wir brauchen zum beispiel
ein funktionierendes lng terminal damit
beispielsweise die abhängigkeit von
russischen gaslieferungen
verhindert werden kann und wir allen
gigaset war aus mit der nahen osten oder
aus den usa einkaufen und hierher
transportieren können ich glaube im
übrigen aber nichts dass die russische
regierung dass russland seinen
lieferverpflichtungen nicht nachkommt
nach den informationen die uns über die
eu kommission vorliegen findet das auch
nicht statt und die leitungskapazitäten
ohne not den zwei reichen auch aus um
europa mit gas zu versorgen
wir sehen allerdings schon mit sorge
dass die putin regierung jetzt eben
preise mit nimmt es sind mitnahmeeffekte
und sehr gut verdient also es wäre gut
wenn die gasproduzenten auf der welt
etwas mehr gas zur verfügung stellen
würden wir kommen aber noch mal zu einem
punkt der in der deutschen innenpolitik
unterbelichtet ist 70 prozent des
energiebedarfs in deutschland der eu
sind fossil gedeckt gas und öl und die
werden importiert und wir werden deshalb
und da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber
gesprochen dringend in eine
internationale wasserstoffwirtschaft
einsteigen müssen der us solar und
windenergie hergestellt wird also grün
ist und klimaneutral und den müssen wir
dann auch zum beispiel über gasleitungen
oder eben verflüssigt hier nach europa
bringen aber ganz kurz sie sind also
auch nicht dafür dass man jetzt schnell
nord und zwei in betrieb nimmt
das wird unser problem alles gesagt
worden
das würde das problem nach unserer
analyse nicht lösen aber ist ein anderes
thema in einem rechtsstaat das ist ein
genehmigungsverfahren anlaufen die
zuständige genehmigungsbehörde
bundesnetzagentur und auch die
eu-kommission prüfen das und da ist es
jetzt an der stelle nicht erforderlich
und auch nicht hilfreich über das
politische einmischung in diesen
rechtlichen prozess gibt ok frauke denkt
was sagen sie wäre das eine möglichkeit
wo man sagen kann das würde unsere
probleme jetzt weil wir wollen ja
irgendwas haben was was wo verbraucher
das gefühl haben jetzt passiert was
damit meine preise nicht ins
unermessliche steigen
wie wäre das gut und richtig wenn man
mehr gas aus russland jetzt schneller zu
uns schaffen würde haben sie da
vertrauen in pudel
na ja da sind jetzt widmet die man
auseinanderhalten muss das eine ist und
jetzt laufen das genehmigungsverfahren
da finde ich auch da sollte man jetzt
nicht so viele theologie und nicht
zuviel kurse geopolitik drauflegen
sondern das muss jetzt entsprechend
laufen das habe ich mal in alle
richtungen das ist der beste ist ein
bisschen ideologie aus zunehmend dieser
frage und wenn sie mich fragen ob ich
vertrauen den putin haben natürlich habe
ich total viel kritik an seiner politik
was das anbelangt aber ich weiß auch
dass ich mal überhaupt wird wo wir
energie sozusagen her importieren also
reden wir mal über erdölproduzenten das
ist jetzt auch nicht so dass du die
dichte der lupenreinen demokraten
besonders stark ist ja so wird dann
denken die länder aus denen der besten
erdöl her importiert ich wollte aber
gerne herrn voll witz an einem punkt
widersprechen haben um anderen punkt
recht geben und zwar also ihren
vorschlag dass man im zweifelsfall
lieber die laufzeit der atomkraftwerke
verlängert dann würde ich keinem element
wieder sprechen und sagen ich glaube
dass sie setzen auf atomkraft ist am
ende das spiel mit russischem roulette
nach so vielen jahrzehnten kernenergie
haben wir immer noch kein sicheres
endlager
dann müssen wir einfach rausgehen ja
also bevor wir das machen sollte dann
doch lieber nutzt in zwei schneller in
betrieb gehen aber nein da bin ich ganz
bei ihnen es gibt ja eigentlich die
gepflogenheit dass eine amtierende
regierung sich komplett zurück hält und
nur noch verwaltet jetzt haben aber eine
situation die sehr brisantes und auch
wenn die ampel jetzt irgendwie nach und
nach zusammen kommt werden ja die
koalitionsverhandlungen auf eine weile
dauern das heißt wir werden nicht schon
in der nächsten woche entsprechend eine
neue regierung und kraft zimmer oder wer
im bundestag für die nicht sofort
eingesetzt werden und die leute die
jetzt frieren die von strom oder gas
sternen betroffen sind das ist eine
akute not da muss im gehandelt werden
deswegen haben ja auch die
sozialverbände zum beispiel den jetzt
sich noch amtierende sozialminister
angeschrieben und gesagt dass er bei der
erhöhung der regelbedarf jetzt schneller
zwischendurch öffnen muss also da würde
ich schon sagen natürlich ist ein
gewisses augenmaß gefragt wenn der
regierung nur noch amtiert aber wenn
entsprechende nöte anstehen kann man
auch vom amtierenden regierung verlangen
dass sie da jetzt aktiv wird er
dazu ich freue mich natürlich über das
lob
wir wollen ja natürlich auch dass
diejenigen die möglicherweise in der
kälte ist es nicht auch noch im dunklen
sitzen und daher mein gedanke bevor wir
das allerschlimmste erleben müssen
vielleicht sogar über mehrere tage
hinweg noch stärker abhängig werden von
europäischen ausland was
stromlieferungen angeht sollte es hier
kein tempo kein denkverbot geben und
auch kein sprach verbot darüber geben
die laufzeiten zu verlängern es ist ja
kein grundsätzlicher ausstieg aus der
bereits getroffenen entscheidung die
kernkraft in deutschland nicht weiter
nutzen so weit gehe ich gar nicht es
geht darum das schlimmste zu verhindern
so gesehen halte ich das für
erträglich und wie viel hoffnung haben
sie in die eu kommission sind
jetzt am der eu gipfel der jetzt
wochenende stattfand donnerstag und
freitag das soll es ja auch genau darum
geht dass man schaut er hat man einen
stabilen europäischen einen robusten
gasmarkt wie es heißt ist das was man
sagt das würde auf ihnen helfen
grundsätzlich sind europäische über
einen fünften nationalen über einen
kampf natürlich immer vorzuziehen und
wenn in dem bereich entscheidungen
getroffen werden die deutschlands ich
gebrauchen das wort etwas disziplinieren
dann befürworte ich das auch in diesem
zusammenhang
gucken wir noch mal darauf was die
verbraucher auch tun können herr müller
wenn man jetzt weil viele der maßnahmen
werden ja dauern bei der vorstellung des
der konjunkturprognose der letzten woche
sagte professor holte müller ohne
konsumverzicht ist eine spürbare
reduktion der co2 emissionen nicht zu
erzielen wir müssen uns da wir werden
unseren gürtel enger schnallen müssen
ist das was was auch bei den
verbrauchern noch nicht ganz angekommen
ist also ich glaube wenn der satz so
gefallen ist wie bei herbig geht hier
ich kenne den kontext nicht dann wirkt
er auf mich leicht arrogant weil von
oben herab mit dem erhobenen zeigefinger
konsum verzicht zu predigen aus einer
privilegierten position finde ich
persönlich ganz fertig aber was richtig
ist ist natürlich können verbrauchen
verbraucher selber etwas tun sie können
erstens die chancen eines
liberalisierten energiemarktes nutzen
indem sie den anbieter wechseln das ist
in den letzten tagen etwas schwieriger
geworden weil natürlich großer anbieter
jetzt auch auf die situation reagieren
aber wir sehen nach wie vor im strom im
gasmarkt ich kann ein anbieter wechseln
ich kann damit etwas sparen zweiter
also natürlich lassen wir haben sich
genau wir haben noch nicht im übermaß
weil wir eine diskussion führen die noch
nicht in den stromrechnungen unmittelbar
angekommen ist das verzögert sich immer
etwas aber ich wage die prognose
november dezember werden wir das
verschärft sehen zweitens natürlich kann
auch jede und jeder für sich energie
sparen und viele menschen tun das schon
aber man kann ihn dabei weiterhelfen das
sind gute informationen das ist beratung
vor ort und das ist das was wir auch im
ampel ergebnis sehen die jungs ergebnis
sehen die nächste bundesregierung möchte
die sanierung von privaten gebäuden
unterstützen das kann ich nur
unterstreichen das ist gut für die
wirtschaft aber ist es natürlich ganz
ganz entscheidend um das eigene
portemonnaie zu entlasten den eigenen
co2 bilanz zu entlasten auch dabei kann
man hilfe und unterstützung bekommen wir
sehen die pläne für solardächer ich
ergänze noch wärmepumpen also es gibt in
deutschland viele möglichkeiten
energieeffizienter zu leben und die
große hoffnung liegt natürlich dass wir
beim umstieg der mobilität einen schritt
vorankommen wenn ich nicht mehr benzin
oder diesel tanken muss sondern elektro
fahren kann ist das heute schon
günstiger das kann sich nicht jeder in
der anderen ecke leiterin erstmal teuer
aber richtig aber der betrieb ist heute
schon deutlich günstiger und darum kann
ich die nächste bundesregierung nur
ermuntern beim ausbau der ladesäulen bei
der vereinheitlichung und vereinfachung
der ladesäulen einen guten schritt
weiter zu gehen damit wir anders mobil
sein können dass es weniger
konsumverzicht verzicht sondern eine
intelligentere klimafreundliche formen
der mobilität frau kipping würden sie
denn sagen weil sie haben klar gesagt
sie kritisieren dass man soll jetzt
nicht die armen leute sollen jetzt nicht
noch irgendwie frieren das ist klar aber
gibt's punkte wo sie sagen ja dass der
wenn wir co2 reduzieren wollen müssen
wir einfach energie sparen alle wo sie
sagen da wäre es wirklich gut da
anzusetzen
ist in der tat ich finde es nicht die
aufgabe von gut verdienten
bundestagsabgeordneten menschen die
weniger haben sie auf vorschriften zu
machen wo sie jetzt anfangen sollen zu
sparen wir wissen aus der statistik also
wirklich ganz nicht an der statistik
dass in der regel bild je reicher ein
haushalt unser größer sein energiebedarf
das heißt natürlich eine umverteilung
von oben zur mitte und nach unten ist
auch ein beitrag zu mehr energie
gerechtigkeit und wir wissen dass ein
großteil der co2-emission es mehr als
zwei drittel auf die reichsten 900
großen konzerne geben das ist gar nicht
die kleine und mittelständische
wirtschaft sondern sind eher 100 große
konzerne und deswegen glaube ich brauche
es am ende den mut zur
ordnungspolitischen maßnahmen und so
ganz konkreten vorschriften basti
produktion an land und dort gebraucht
auch ein mutiger regierung sich
vielleicht mit den größeren und
stärkeren
konzernen anzulegen diesen mut habe ich
jetzt in bisher im sanierungsfall ist ja
nie leider nicht so ausgewiesen was wäre
das für ein verbot könnten sie da
mutiger sein dass man versucht wirklich
dann auch die co2 zu reduzieren und eben
dann energie zu sparen
da ist ja das sind jungs papieren
wirklich sehr gutes ergebnis denn es
wird ja richtig tempo gemacht bei der
gebäudeeffizienz bei der modernisierung
von wohnraum
aber eben auch bei der infrastruktur die
leitungs infrastruktur aber bereits
angesprochen die ladeinfrastruktur hat
herr müller zurecht angesprochen denn
das sind ja die ganz praktischen
probleme wir haben ja in deutschland was
den klimaschutz angeht kein zielsetzung
problem sondern ein zielerreichung
problem stichwort sektor kopplungen es
gibt bürokratische hemmnisse im übrigen
auch wenn jemand ein elektrolyseur
betreibt und wasserstoff herzustellen
mit überschüssiger regenerativer energie
musste er früher eeg umlage bezahlen das
ist jetzt glücklicherweise ausgelaufen
diese maßnahmen müssen wir beschleunigen
denn diese investitionen in alternative
regenerative energien die machen uns
natürlich dann auch unabhängiger von den
preissprüngen auf dem darß und ölmarkt
und da fallen uns eben versäumnisse der
vergangenheit auf die füße da bleibt uns
jetzt akut nichts anderes übrig als mehr
tempo zu machen zu beschleunigen und
klammer auf steigende energiepreise sind
natürlich aus klimaschutzgründen bei
fossilen energien auch langfristigen
anreiz eben auf klimaschonende
technologien umzusteigen die müssen aber
bezahlt werden und diese investitionen
müssen sich rechnen dafür soll es ja
auch anreize geben ich glaube das ist
der richtige weg und bis dahin
kurzfristig ist es durchaus möglich dass
eben auch jede bürgerin jeder bürger
sich überlegt stichwort freizeitverkehr
beispielsweise wo herzlich prozent aller
verkehre ausmacht dass man sich doch
noch mal überlegt ob man vielleicht auf
eine unnötige farbauswahl verzichtet
oder auf ein anderes verkehrsmittel
umsteigt helfer als gibt's punkt wo sie
sagen da verzichten sie da würden sie
gerne energiesparen
mittelständische unternehmen sind nicht
dafür bekannt dass sie verschwenderisch
agieren ganz im gegenteil das ist fast
ein angebot ökonomischer
50 energieeffizienz zu verhalten ich
wage sogar die behauptung das ist in der
vergangenheit geschehen ohne dass
überhaupt ist gesetzlicher regeln
gegeben hat die dies vorschreiben aber
ich möchte die gelegenheit nutzen
ein zukünftiges mitglied der
bundesregierung mit herrn teurer dazu zu
verpflichten anders als die jetzige
bundesregierung bei der wasserstoff
strategie die nur vorgeblich tatsächlich
für den mittelstand ausrede ist bislang
ob sich die konzerne profitieren da
bitte darauf zu achten dass die
mittelstandsfreundlich ausgelegt wird
dass diese unternehmen dort auch eine
chance haben tatsächlich zu
partizipieren
ist angekommen hoffentlich eher teurer
nehmen sie das einfach mit nutzen sie
die debatte und das miteinander hier für
all diese display diese diskussion um
die gestiegenen energiepreise ihnen ganz
herzlichen dank diebe zuschauerin liebe
zuschauer vielen dank fürs zuschauen
morgen schauen wir auf den eu-gipfel und
schauen um auf den streit mit polen ich
hoffe sie sind dabei bis dahin tschüss